Consider it a gesture of good faith
good faith for what what you look cool
a team up
Welcome back everyone this will be my
full video for the boys season three episode 5.
there was a whole bunch of easter eggs we got way
more jensen ackles soldier boy so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos as bad as
it seems like it's gotten for everyone on the show
things are only going to get crazier and crazier
towards the finale careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet we'll just start at
the beginning and work our way through shot by
shot talking about easter eggs and wtf moments
starting with the episode title the last time to
look on this world of lies and that's a reference
to the comic book volume 4 issue 4 they're
basically just proceeding with the next part
of the story in the comics but remember they are
changing a lot of things from the comics so some
of the things are similar some of the things
are quite a bit different really the big thing
in this episode was introducing paul reiser as
their version of the tv show's legend he's a huge
character in the comics that's meant to be a big
stan lee parody like he's a legend in the world of
the boys because of all of his exploits but also
in real life stan lee is a legend because he has
such a history in comic books the actual opening
scene starts with mother's milk watching the tape
of the russians testing soldier boy's powers
after they captured him they reveal a bunch of
big twists and confirm some of our theories about
what really happened to soldier boy like he really
got sold out they really tried to get rid of
him by selling him off to the russians without
actually selling him like crimson countess says
that the russians didn't actually pay them any
money they just hated them that much and wanted
to get rid of them that bad all meant to be a
parallel for just how terrible homelander is in
the way the rest of the seven think of homelander
like we all hate you nobody loved you finding a
really terrible dumpster fire with another really
terrible dumpster fire like soldier boy himself is
supposed to be something of a human dumpster fire
lizzie kind of referenced that during the episode
a little bit too when he's trying to reacclimate
to modern society like what the hell is going on
here the whole crazy montage here of them dosing
him with high amounts of radiation sulfuric acid
all kinds of things like testing his physical
durability is just trying to show you how powerful
he is that he can actually stand up to homelander
within the world of the boys there have been a
couple superheroes that they've had on the show
that have been at that level of power like
soldier boy is the newest one but kimiko was
also meant to be super strong super powerful next
to homelander maeve is also supposed to be one of
the most powerful superheroes next to homelander
but the whole idea is that homelander is meant
to be like a level above all of them like that's
how much more powerful he is than everyone else
even if all those other people teamed up to fight
him physically they couldn't overpower him that's
why they're using soldier boy's new special power
and they clarify what was going on with that too
it didn't just disable kimiko's healing factor
it literally burned the compound v out of her
body that's why she seemingly doesn't have any
powers because of the other easter eggs during
her storyline and what's going on with frenchie i
do think that it's meant to be a permanent kind of
thing and she'll have to find a way to get her
powers back but i'll get to that in a second
the bigger thing here is the threat that soldier
boy now poses to homelander the way the showrunner
explained this the way they're using soldier
boy's special ability here is that it's meant
to terrify homelander because like who is he if
he doesn't have his compound v superpowers and
it also explains how they would theoretically be
able to kill him because they'd be able to turn
off all those compound beef superpowers maybe
i mean we think that they could do it but like
for instance victoria newman's head popping
skill seems like it's not powerful enough to
kill homelander so if even that's not powerful
enough to kill him it'll be interesting to see
what happens when soldier boy actually tries to
use this special power against homelander like
their building up is this huge thing but wouldn't
it be a huge wtf cliffhanger kind of ending if
he uses it and it still doesn't work on homelander
in the comics and on the show they really do want
to make it feel like he is invincible later in
the episode butcher also says ryan who's kind
of like their greatest hope against him won't be
ready to actually fight him for many years but the
whole thing at the beginning of the episode with
mother's milk yelling at butcher about him not
caring about anyone that's right out of the comics
butcher is meant to be portrayed as being just as
bad as homelander just in a completely different
direction i've said this in many videos before
like even later in the episode he winds up dosing
mother's milk so that mother's milk can't throw
their plans off the rails and try to kill soldier
boy before they can use him against homelander
even though i don't think that mother's milk would
actually be able to kill soldier boy if he tried
butcher makes a kermit the frog reference when
huey starts throwing up like butcher did when
their compound b powers wore off because they
throw up green the vision that he sees of huey
i believe is meant to be his little brother huey
represents the innocence i think that he remembers
in his little brother so he kind of thinks of huey
as his little brother so huey threatening to go
off the rails getting addicted to this compound v
powers might help bring butcher back from the edge
of darkness but the whole idea is this is just
the beginning like huey's gonna get way darker way
more addicted to this compound v they name ashley
the new ceo of vaude because they just fired stan
edgar formally they even did it on that fake vote
twitter account in real life like thank you for
all your service but he's going to be parting ways
for the company permanently the whole joke here
is that just meant to be a puppet position now
because technically homelander runs everything
and he just runs roughshod over this brand new
board that they've appointed the reason he starts
to freak out space out the camera pushes in on
him and things get all quiet is meant to show his
fear that what stan edgar said to him is actually
coming true lego i don't actually know anything
about running a company i'm stupid i'm gonna
end up revealing myself there a couple moments
like that during the episode where he just kind
of spaces out and he gets really pissed off at
everyone because he's super afraid that he's not
gonna know what to do like oh yeah it's actually
hard to run a giant multi-billion dollar company
and just to be clear i don't think that stan edgar
is completely gone on the show i think that he'll
come back before the finale and the whole idea is
that black noir seems like he's been more loyal to
stan edgar than the homelander but it's basically
the same situation all over the other parts
of the company too like they fire their head
a crime analytics division and name the deep as
their replacement and then he winds up firing
pretty much the entire department like now it's
the idiots running the asylum huey's honest about
everything that happened in russia with things
going off the rails and about him taking the
temporary compound bee but the whole reason why he
lies about making their deal with soldier boy to
use him as a weapon against homelander is because
both he and butcher are afraid of people ruining
that before they're able to actually kill homeland
or like they're that confident that soldier boy
will be able to do it even though i think that
that's going to wind up being a misdirect like
he'll probably still be too powerful for soulja
boy to take down because it's all meant to be
part of the storyline with huey just going darker
and darker and darker and they want to show you
how that's going to wind up being a dead end for
him like you're going to wind up selling your soul
out and it's not gonna pay off for you all tying
back to the idea that huey told her earlier that
we have to be just as bad as the other guys in
order to beat them when really that is going to
be a dead end like becoming as bad as the bad
guys just makes you an even worse guy and he's
really probably just going to wind up getting more
and more addicted to the compound v mave brings
butcher five more replacement files confirming
that they did run out earlier but now because they
have five more they have even more than they got
the first time this is probably gonna last them
for the next couple episodes when butcher says
that he's also been sober for over a year this
meant to be around the time becca died at the end
of season 2 and they took ryan into custody that's
around when he got sober so the whole idea
is that huey is slowly falling off the wagon
butcher also literally falls off the wagon because
he starts taking a drink with maeve who also falls
off the wagon after being sober for the past four
months while training to fight homelander herself
and then they totally wind up getting it on
like butcher thinks of himself as kind of trash
maeve also thinks of herself as trash pretty much
everybody in the show is probably eventually going
to think of themselves as trash because of all
the things that they're doing how dark they're all
getting that's one of the funny things about the
boys is that everybody on all the groups of the
show are meant to be kind of terrible people at
heart the best thing about the show like the most
positive aspect of the show is meant to be huey
and starlight's relationship which is why i think
that they'll be able to redeem themselves by the
end like huey won't completely go off the deep end
butcher maybe not so much though they also reveal
during this conversation too that they're having
that they're kind of worried about ryan turning
into another homeland or like being just as bad as
him if they push him too soon but they do confirm
that they are planning to eventually use him as a
contingency plan against homelanders someday
if it's necessary which it probably will be
the whole thing with the frenchie and kimiko
storyline is about her dream coming true remember
she kept talking about how she wished she never
had her powers and now it's true like she got rid
of all her powers at least temporarily that's the
reason why she's so happy and they have that huge
dance number to the judy garland song despite the
fact that she's still really injured like she's in
a lot of physical pain but she couldn't be happier
because she achieved her dream and she found a way
to talk again if it wasn't clear she's always
been able to physically speak but because of
all of her trauma that she experienced everything
that happened to her and how she originally got
compound v powers mentally she had this block that
just left her unable to speak the whole thing with
little nina forcing frenchie to come back into
the belly of the biso to speak into organization
and start killing people again doing whatever she
wanted i think it's meant to be a big choice for
kimiko down the line like she got rid of her power
she got her wish but in order to save frenchie
from little nina kimiko will probably be forced
to take compound v again becoming the very thing
that she hated originally i think that's meant to
dovetail with the whole storyline with butcher and
huey and mother's milk about them not wanting them
to take the compound b because hey we're better
than that we're not supposed to be like these
other superheroes they're all terrible people if
we take the compound b we're just as bad as them
they confirmed that a train did inform home later
on what super sonic did he really did sell out
the team then they had that whole funny scene with
bluehawk going full karen when he confronts him on
going after all those african-american communities
and he winds up almost killing his brother so when
starlight is yelling at him saying that he did
this for nothing like he's not helping anyone it's
all meant to be his worst fears come true like
he sold out super sonic for nothing the scene of
soldier boy making it back into the city is meant
to be a reference to captain america coming out
of the ice after all those years in the avengers
movie and having to re-acclimate to modern life
because soldier boy is very literally meant to
be a parody of captain america he's just meant to
be the douchiest version of captain america like a
peacemaker type of character so the big twist here
is that unlike captain america he loses control of
his powers with this big ptsd flashback killing
a bunch of people and they also confirmed that
back in the 80s his team tried to get rid of
him the same way that the seven are trying to
get rid of homelander because both of the teams
hated them so much because they were just so bad
they confirmed that ashley's stepfather is one
of these conspiracy nuts who totally buys into
everything that comes out of homelanders mouth
they kind of foreshadowed this in earlier episodes
where he started leaning in when homeland or went
off the rails like oh this is amazing i'll believe
anything that comes out of this guy's mouth it's
meant to be a big q and on kind of reference like
this big conspiracy theory rant that they all go
on that's why he mentions the whole facebook thing
and connecting back to stan edgar's comments about
having real power meaning being able to control
what people think they also reference this whole
idea when homelander is later talking about the
storm front stance the group that she used to
create all that misinformation on the internet
that are calling themselves the storm chasers on
4chan the big twist here too and homelander kind
of calls this out is that it's not a conspiracy
if it's all true if they're all coming to get
you and that's kind of true but not quite in
the way that homelander thinks like stan edgar
probably does want to get rid of homelander but
he himself is not responsible for what's happening
right now with soldier boy the reason he's back is
because butcher inadvertently freed him eventually
this will wind up turning into a prophecy because
later butcher does get the idea to use soldier boy
against homelander so yes homelander is a total
nut but he is a little bit correct just not
quite in the way that he thinks he is then like i
said they introduced paul reiser as their version
of the tv show's legend he's meant to be a big
parody of stan lee in the comics and he's more
of an information broker in the comics on the tv
show they're saying that he used to have madeline
stillwell's job managing all the superheroes back
during the 70s and the 80s during the core era
when soldier boy was really active and at least on
the tv show the nickname the legend was given to
him because of all of his sexual exploits like he
has all these jokes about all the crazy sex stuff
that he did the funny thing with the marlon brando
jokes too is when he says he convinced marlon
brando to take a lower quote on the steel knight
movie i think that's meant to be a reference to
the first superman movie because steel knight man
of steel superman but all those jokes about marlon
brando and all the crazy stuff that he got up to
that's meant to be a real life thing like there
are real life rumors about all the crazy stuff
that marlon brando did that's one of the funny
things about the boys is the crazy stuff that they
do some of it is actually based on real life stuff
you also notice in the background of his apartment
he has a bunch of vintage posters like this one
for black noir back in the past in the 70s and
80s from a movie that he did there's also an
advertisement for the hero that stormfront used to
pretend to be liberty she did budweiser ads when
she was the liberty persona they had flashbacks to
it during season two then also like i said earlier
this whole thing with maeve telling homelander
like oh this relationship that we used to have
i never loved you i was always afraid of
you and i always hated you is meant to
be a parallel for everything that happened with
soldier boy crimson countess in the payback team
so later when crimson countess is talking to
soldier boy she basically has the exact same
conversation plays out the exact same way almost
i didn't love you i hated you from the start
i hated you except maeve is still alive whereas
crimson countess is not the whole thing with black
noir grabbing her and then ashley saying that
she's at the global wellness retreat i think
that's going to be the show's version of herogasm
this is the second time on the show that they've
mentioned this the next episode of the show is
literally the hirogasm episode which is why i
think that that global relish retreat is secretly
the code word for herogasm if you haven't read
the comics herogasm is basically like the worst
version of superhero spring break it's a retreat
for superheroes they have every year this is the
most debaucherous thing that you've ever seen ever
make sure to bring a whole bunch of penicillin
and a whole bunch of hand sanitizer i love the
super wtf but super hilarious seth rogen cameo
scene with crimson couches ruling that she's
also making money on the side as a cam girl but if
you remember seth rogen also cameoed in an earlier
episode in season 1 as the director of this black
noir series of movies so i think the idea is that
he's still playing that same character but on
the side he secretly has this big kink where
he pays for all these cam girl websites and he's
just obsessed with crimson countess if you didn't
know in real life seth rogen is also one of the
producers of the boys tv show he's the person
that got charlize theron to agree to do the cameo
scene as the fake version of stormfront in that
movie in the beginning of the series when she
starts her show the song that she puts on is
the chimps don't cry song that she was showing
to kimiko earlier on the show then before things
get really crazy obviously they cut it short when
butcher takes her out but they reveal a lot of our
theories about what really happened to soldier boy
so the whole idea is that crimson countess knew
everything about what happened to soldier boy in
the past like she was in on it with stan edgar and
the others because they all hated him and they
wanted to get rid of him somehow so they just
sold him out to the russians without literally
selling him out like they didn't get paid for it
they didn't really know what the russians were
going to do to him they just wanted the russians
to basically put him metaphorically on ice just
keep him busy for this whole time and it's just
meant to show you how terrible people thought that
he was and how butcher is basically trying to use
a dumpster fire to fight another dumpster
fire like putting him up against homelander
jensen ackles said he had a lot of fun
playing this character but there were a
lot of moments where he wasn't sure whether or
not he'd be able to do all the crazy wtf stuff
that the showrunner asked him to do and
the funny thing is is the shoulder of the
boys was the showrunner and the creator of the
supernatural tv show which is the reason why you
see a bunch of supernatural actors showing
up on the tv show like for instance next
season jeffrey dean morgan is supposed to have
a cameo scene when huey makes the trainspotting
reference that movie also features a lot of kids
falling to addiction like huey is currently doing
getting addicted to the compound v powers he's
basically talking like an addict that's how this
conversation between them plays out that movie
also starred a very young ewan mcgregor who is
also currently in the obi-wan kenobi series that
i'm doing episodes for with hayden christensen
hello there butcher then reveals that yes he's
just getting as terrible as you thought that he
was going to get getting darker and darker dosing
mother's milk with a sedative to prevent him
from sending things off the rails with soldier boy
even though i don't think that mother's milk would
actually be able to kill soldier boy if he tried
revealing the bargain that he makes with soldier
boy like we're doing a team up soldier boy i've
come to bargain huey turning away from starlight
and following butcher and soldier boy is this
meant to make you wonder how dark things are
going to get before they get better but i think
ultimately the show wants to be hopeful about
starlight and huey because their relationship
like the two of them together are like the one
hopeful bright light on the show like i said next
week's episode is herogasm it is going to be the
most debaucherous thing that you've ever seen
on television ever my full video for the boys
season 3 episode 6 will post next week after they
release that if you spotted any other big easter
eggs in the show that i didn't mention write them
below in the comments and let me know what you
think they're gonna do during herogasm like how
they actually gonna adapt that for television
the real big news that just happened is that
hbo also just confirmed that they're doing a jon
snow game of thrones sequel series so i just did a
video for that click here to learn what's going on
and click here for my other new marvel
wonder man disney plus series announcement
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!